we're not going to keep global warming
below 1.5 degrees
unless we dramatically cut emissions of
another greenhouse gas
methane that's the conclusion of the
united nations environment program
in a new report it says methane is 10
times more powerful than carbon dioxide
at trapping heat in the atmosphere yet
levels
have more than doubled since
pre-industrial times so where's it all
coming from
well the report says human activity
accounts for around
million tons of methane being released
every year
agriculture mainly livestock and rice
cultivation
accounts for 40 but fossil fuels and
waste including landfill
are also significant sources the good
news
is that existing solutions could reduce
methane emissions from human activity
by 45 by 2030 that's
180 million tons a year
and around a third of the measures would
actually end up saving money
that includes better management of coal
mines and detection of gas leaks
keeping food and other organic waste out
of landfill
and eating less meat and growing rice
more sustainably
because methane only lasts in the
atmosphere for a decade the impact would
be swift
preventing around 0.3 degrees of global
warming
by the 2040s
every half a degree matters hugely
and even every tenth of a degree and
just one example
is that three tenths of a degree
corresponds to to more than
70 billion lost hours of labor and
that's people that you know are working
outside
places that can't be in air-conditioned
people working in agriculture in
construction so they're real
costs to the economy all of these these
tenths of a degrees yes
sound very minor but they're not not at
all
reducing carbon emissions to net zero is
still essential for stabilizing the
climate in the long term
but the quickest bang for your buck is
tackling methane